الوثائق التي قد تهز ثقه الحلفاء
بالولايات المتحده وتعقد العلاقات
الخارجيه ظهرت للمره الاولى الى العلم على
قناه مراسله الصفحات العشر الاولى طبعت في
الثامن والعشرين من فبراير والثاني من
مارس على منصه باسم ديسكورد وهي منصه
دردشه يرتادها هواه الالعاب الالكترونيه
وفق صحيفه وصف جنر الامريكيه وظلت المواد
المصنفه سريه بين مجموعه صغيره من مستخدمي
المنصه حتى اوائل مارس الماضي قبل ان يقوم
مستخدم اخر باعاده نشرها في مجموعه اخرى
اكبر عددا طبعا غير ان خروج هذه الوثائق
للعلن على يد حساب دعائيه روسيه على منصه
تيليجرام هذا التسريب الاستخباراتي وصفه
بالاسوء والاكثر ضررا منذ عقود يختلف عن
سابقاته اي ويكيليكس وادن بحداثه الوثائق
فعمر بعض المستندات لا يتجاوز الاربعين
يوما لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات